hi my name is david sedaris and i feel
fantastic about being conan o'brien's
friend that's so nice because last time
you came on you said apprehensive i know
but i didn't know you
and then i got to say
i said to people afterwards i said he's
the greatest his greatest guy i said you
know there's one thing you know you see
somebody on television or even if you go
on television you know because that's
more of a kind of a mill situation you
know and there's a pre-interview and all
that stuff
but i said no he if you met him
i said you'd be crazy about him that's
so nice i now of course my mind goes
right to what's wrong with the
television persona
why did that
why didn't that grab you it's almost as
if you're saying and this is how i hear
things
um isn't it crazy conan o'brien seems
like a really great guy despite what you
would think that's what i hear anybody
else uh
guessing what i meant was you know what
it's not about you it's about me because
if i have to go on tv
i just think i just want this to be over
and i'm i'm
really nervous about it and i'm
terrified and i'm trying to remember
what it is that i'm supposed to say so
it's really not about you it's about me
uh
um but this is a bit different i don't
know in part because it's not being
filmed
and
she's gonna tell them that there's
actually there are cameras there are
four cameras here so this is being how
many
there's a live audience watching at the
staples center
35 000 people are watching right now but
when i first did your show
your show had just started
oh that was so that was a long time ago
yeah and things were pretty rough back
then i would often cry halfway through
the interview
for no reason but i think we were both
with the same people back then yeah yeah
yeah we were actually we don't we don't
need to uh
find new partners every few years no we
don't need to do that no that's for
other people
someone's relationships gotta last right
how long have you because you know i
know you've been with hugh for quite a
long time 31 years
31 years i've been with my wife for 22.
six of those years quite happy
really off the charts
we are people that go the long haul
that's what i say
my sister amy was here she would
attribute that to our astrological signs
oh oh she's constantly trying to convert
me
to i've never been a believer i don't
understand what the position of the
stars has to do with anything no uh and
so
i adore your sister she's one of the
most talented people i've ever met and
just a delightful person but i think
she's off her rocker if she thinks that
pluto's position has anything to do with
how we behave or what we're doing you
know what i mean i it's no i feel the
same way yeah i feel that about
astrology i feel that way about uh
ghosts yes i hate hearing about ghosts
when you're at a dinner or something and
someone says
maya you know i stayed at this holiday
inn and it's haunted and okay that
holiday inn is seven years old
and my house
my house in england is 500 years old
why is it my house if anyone's house was
going to be haunted it would be much i
love a seven-year-old structure being
haunted who's haunting it well it was
someone who worked in obama's second
administration
[Laughter]
he uh worked it with osha but uh what
happened oh he just got a blister and it
got out of control and he passed away
but he haunts and and the other thing
when we've talked about this is it
really irritates me that
there doesn't seem to be any rules about
why a place is haunted meaning sometimes
a place is haunted because the person
died there which makes sense to me but
then there are other people that say oh
no it's haunted by an old coal miner who
oh really well where'd he die did he die
here in the house oh no he died like 65
miles from here
but then he took public transportation
and set up shop in this house that was
built four years ago that has solar
panels you're like
no no according to an expert that amy
talked to ghosts can come into your
house by way of second-hand clothing so
if you go to goodwill
and you bring bring home a t-shirt that
could that could be bringing a ghost
into your house if you buy a piece of
antique furniture yeah oh my gosh
that way yeah it's like a deer tick yeah
a ghost now yeah it you know so when you
when you when your kids have been out
playing you should check them for ghosts
when they come back in the house to make
sure that everything's
well no no no hold on a second there's
an old widower of a sea captain clinging
to your cav
but see that way you could have had your
house built for you and you could move
into it and there could be a ghost
because somebody who came to put new
filters in the air conditioner
the ghost could have traveled
also that way i'm not
ghosts are often up to not much
they're you you know you someone will
you'll say how do you know there's a
ghost that said well you know at night
i can hear there's a there's a radiator
grate
that's on the third floor but towards
the back and it's slightly always
adjusting you're like
if you were in the afterlife for all
eternity that's what you'd be doing is
adjusting a radiator grade but they
always make it seem like okay you have
ghosts in your house but you're so
self-centered you're so shallow that you
can't pick up on them right so it's
something about your personality right
it's a
you're deficient in some way because you
can't pick up on the ghost that this
other
in tune person can pick up on it right
right it's just [ __ ] from beginning
to end the ghost thing yeah ghosts
astrology um amy
sedaris if you're out there listening uh
we're not having it we're not having it
and
your brother and i are ganging up on you
well we need to arrange an intervention
yes